[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
chess openings explained today i wanted
to take you through the remaining lines
in the fischer sozen attack and i
already have
uh quite a position pulled up here we'll
get to that eventually
so in the first lines of course
in the fischer susan i went over last
week let's just do a brief review here
we have of course the opening moves of
the nightdorf
and then we have bishop c4 fig are
signifying the fischer susan attack
from here e6 is the main move
and last week we looked at all the lines
covering
uh coming after uh 7 bishop b3
and bishop e7 uh and well actually
not quite all the lines we looked at all
the lines after this main move
f4 these are really the most complex
lines
uh and there were two really critical
variations that don't see a lot of play
over the board but are very very testing
to this bishop e7 move in this
8f4 line and i went over those uh
really really in depth and there were a
lot of comments on the video saying wow
this is this is way too much i can never
play like this
and i did want to to briefly just
restate
that it's it's pretty unlikely you're
gonna go too deep into one of those
uh variations that i i went into i
covered them
so much in depth because if i didn't it
would feel as though
i did a poor job of showing
really the most testing stuff but that's
uh
not always the most likely thing for you
guys to see
and so some of the main ideas here where
we wanted to play b5
and bishop b7 pointing out that this f4
move was leaving a big weakness
on e4 uh and so hopefully if you guys
want more of that
go check out that first lecture again
today what i'm going to cover
are the lines with a different eighth
move here
other than the move f4 and then we're
also going to look at all of the
variations where white castles king side
be it on this move which is the second
most popular move
or if he castles king's side after uh
bishop b3 it's not going to make too
much of a difference to us so that's
what we are going over today uh
and to start off with i wanted to save
all those lines
where white castles king side for
a later uh well actually later in the
same lecture
and i wanted to jump right into these
different eighth moves for white after
the move bishop b3
so in this position uh exactly
the most common most popular move
is actually to play this move 8 g4
as manny is saying in the chat room
right now
and this move at first glance is
actually rather scary
for black to face in the database there
are a lot of games
after the move h6 which does for the
moment stop g5
but it sort of just makes the problem
worse after the mover of g1
and in my opinion white actually does
enjoy a slight advantage
in these lines the threat of g5 coming
and opening up the g
file is actually a pretty strong one for
black to face
so i wasn't quite happy with this move
h6
there's also this choice of playing
knight c6 but
after g5 white actually does get a very
very significant
advantage on the king's side and you
know there are other moves like
castles and d5 but none of these were
really giving me
the uh the line i was actually hoping
for here
and i did eventually find it in the move
eight queen a5 uh and this
is the recommendation that i have for
you here
today eight queen a5 and the reason i
like this move so much
is it's not stopping g5 directly
by any defensive passive means it's more
about
creating more immediate attacking
threats on the queen side
before white is able to really get this
this attack going and i have three moves
highlighted here on the board
uh bishop d2 queen e2 and f3
why are these the only three moves i
have highlighted
well that's because queen a5 has the
huge upside
of creating the threat of knight takes
e4
and so we are for the moment stopping g5
through tactical means
because knight takes e4 is just going to
be an easily winning position now
for black so queen a5 is the move that i
like
against g4 uh now f3
is by you know a whole one game
the most common move here uh and i'm
gonna save that for last because i do
think that is actually white's best try
let's first look at the tempting bishop
d2 i feel like this is
perhaps the most natural move to to make
in this position for white
you say you put your queen on a dumb
square i'm gonna play bishop d2
threaten that queen indirectly and make
you move it again
but in fact i think black actually does
enjoy a small advantage
if white does go for this variation
and it's after the move you might not
expect you know you play queen a5
your opponent plays bishop d2 asks you
very politely to move the queen again
move it out of the way of the bishop and
what does black do he moves the queen
closer
to the bishop with the move queen b4 and
this is actually a pretty powerful move
here
um for black
now this is sort of a difficult threat
to me
on the knight placed on the d4 square
here
there's no real good discoveries for
white if you try something like knight
d5
well i'm just going to take here this
threat isn't nearly
good enough queen takes e4 is quite
strong
and black would be winning knight b5
for the moment defends the knight but
black can just very comfortably move
this
queen here and then all of a sudden too
many pieces are hanging
so these discoveries are sort of uh out
of the game
at least these attacking discoveries
move knight c to e2 i think is perhaps
the main line
i also wanted to mention if something
like g5
we are quite happy to collect this
knight on d4
and after takes we will just drop our
queen back to the king's side
and this is just a healthy extra pawn
for black here you know white can try to
develop
but we'll just develop our pieces as
well knight c6
and after something like queen h5 just
the simple g6 is a nice solidifying move
that black can employ in these positions
here
so uh rather than something like g5 or
some strange discovery
the best move for white is likely just
to move knight c to e2
uh retreating the knight defending d4
and
uh uh discovering an attack on the queen
now there's only one game that made it
this far and that i could tell that
emery tate
actually played with the white pieces
and in that game black played the move
queen b6
i think a small improvement is actually
just to bring this queen out to c5 uh
the point being
we are allowing ourselves some lateral
defense here
and if our opponent ever tries to play
the move bishop e3
well immediately there are problems here
but we aren't so unhappy
bringing this queen back to a5 with with
check anyways
uh so probably the best move here for
white well i say probably definitely
i've analyzed it
is to play the move f3 this is sort of
just the best way to deal with this
threat to the e4 pawn and the g4 pawn
in tandem but like i said the point of
playing this queen a5 move
is we're creating enough threats
immediately that we slow down white's
threats of playing g5
and we continue that trend now by
playing the move e5
this knight simply has nowhere to go
besides the f5 square
and after knight f5 we can just capture
this guy
off the board uh just for example g
text f5 or e takes f5 it doesn't matter
too much
black's gonna play knight c6 and black
sort of just has a really nice hold on
the position here uh it's tough for
white to actually get this rook to this
open file with our active queen on c5
we have some pressure along the c file
as well with this queen on c5 as
as well powerful queen uh bishop e3 for
the moment isn't going to be possible
and in the meantime black is going to
start pushing some pawns
on the queen side or even pushing some
pawns in the center of the board
and that's sort of where i'm i'm going
to leave the analysis here
there are no games in this current
position
and while this is a very very complex
position i don't think it's one
that is solved by you know more opening
analysis
i think it's just a fun complex middle
game position i don't think white's
doing too badly here
but i definitely think uh black is is
one
with many many chances in this position
uh knight d4 also potential ideas and
uh black might not castle king's side
immediately for the moment e8 is
probably the best square for this king
but at a later date you can imagine
castling queen side even
once the threat of bishop takes f7 has
sort of been dealt with
just an example line knight c3 knight d4
let's say king f1 for example just
getting ready to make this threat we can
take here
and maybe even d5 or queen side castles
or
rook d8 and this is sort of the way you
can imagine
this game sort of flowing from here so
that
is the bishop d2 move dealt with once
again
the key move here queen b4 uh creating
some lateral threats
and knight ce2 is really white's only
choice the queen comes back to c5
we have f3 and then the nice locking
maneuver
is to play the move e5 snatch this
knight off the board
and then just go for play in the center
and the queen side
so of course bishop d2 isn't the only
move let's take a look now at queen e2
sort of white second option
and here we are simply going to revert
uh back to some plans we talked about in
the first lecture
with playing a quick b5 and going for
pressure on white's center
now i do believe white should really try
and prevent the move b4
with the move a3 in this position if
white tries
to sort of attack immediately with the
move g5 stubbornly
well we are in time now to play this
move b4
and challenge this knight on c3 g takes
f6
is no good for white because b takes c3
comes with a stronger threat
then f takes e7 so white is obliged to
move this knight
d1 might be the best square coming
around
to some squares on the king side and now
simply knight fd7
end of f4 let's say knight c5
and we are defending against any
sacrifices
i should also mention the queen being on
a5 has the added bonus of making
this move a lot less attractive as now
knight takes c6
never comes with tempo on the queen uh
just another side bonus of queen a5 you
do have to worry a little bit less
about these sacrifices uh and after f4
knight c5 these sacrifices are of course
you know never
never really happening anymore
uh and then from here it just becomes
very very difficult to continue this uh
initiative on the king's side
for white when you're dealing with all
these threats on
the queen side for example if you just
sort of stubbornly continue with f5
we're going to snatch this bishop off
the board this move is a no-go so c
takes b3
and after queen e5 uh black is
just doing quite well in this position
uh
you know white seemingly has very
aggressively placed pawns
but with this active central queen and
easy development to follow
uh black is is really gonna have no
issues here
and the arrows i pointed out is show if
knight f3 queen b5 is a very elegant
solution uh now offering up the queen
trade
and if this these queens are allowed to
be traded for example queen b5 ab5
it's going to be black who's on the
better uh the better side of things here
with this e4 pawn once again being a
little bit weak
and these pawns being a little bit over
extended
and so that is the queen e2 line in a
nutshell
basically queen e2 we respond with b5
going for b4 play if g5
uh b4 and actually sorry i haven't gone
over the main variation a3 i knew i was
forgetting something
so if g5 immediately that's when we can
reply with b4
and after knight fd7 f4
and knight out to c5 black is very
active play as we just saw
this queen coming to the center and easy
development to follow
uh so the more responsible move by white
is to play a3
slowing down this b4 move for uh just a
moment
and here i actually think black can get
away with just
castling castling is another move that
sort of lessens the threat of these
sacrifices
on e6 and in that way we are preparing
for the move g5 by making knight fd7
uh never an issue
uh because it interferes with our bishop
because castling
is how we are dealing with this e6
sacrifice
and from here white has a few options i
can actually castle king's side but this
is very very counterintuitive
so i focused more on the move bishop d2
uh just for example if king side we
still want to respond
with b4 highlighting the fact that a3
is still pins and just for example if
knight a4
knight c5 is simple enough and you would
get some kind of open position
on the queen side and the point here is
that the play
is more really going to be focused on
these open queen side lines
with these this knight and bishop sort
of sidelined rather than this
uh stunning king side attack that white
is hoping to achieve
and that's sort of the goal here we want
to direct the play over to the queen's
side
um so
uh instead of castles bishop d2 makes
more sense as i was saying got
distracted by the chat for a second
uh and here now we are finally going to
reposition our queen
our stunning queen b4 move has been
prevented so queen b6 is fine
and then here honestly the best move for
white is bishop e3
once again trying to highlight this
queen is misplaced
and now i like the move knight c5 once
again for black
just sort of staying thematic here
defending this guy
attacking this guy and making white's
play rather awkward
it's probably worth it for white to save
this guy with bishop a2
another side bonus of a3 and from here i
do
like just expanding more on the queen
side opening files with something like
b4
and queen takes b4 uh
from here it does sort of become this uh
unfortunate game for white where this
king
has no squares the castle's king queen
side it's sort of suicidal
uh with all these open files coming
against the white king if he stays in
the center he has to deal with these
issues of knight takes e4
and unfortunately i do think king side
castles is sort of white's best bet here
despite having launched this pawn all
the way up to g5
and once again here white can still sort
of stubbornly play
for a king-side attack but the point is
our play on the queen's side is also
coming very very quickly for example
bishop b7
makes a threat on e4 if h4
uh rather than capture on e4 i do like
the move knight c6
just going for rapid development and
this knight
is hanging so queen d2 but now we can
actually
get play in a manner of different ways
for example rook fb8
or one of my favorites just playing a5
and sort of going for a4
and a3 and provoking even more
weaknesses
on the queen side
note now that white really does have to
deal with this otherwise
there are some awkward tactics uh
such as this just winning the e4 pawn
and for example here a5 did have the
bonus of defending our queen so we don't
have to worry about this intermezzo
so f3 for example and from here we can
trade off a piece or two
and find activity somewhere on the queen
side
with any one of these moves or even
breaking in the center
and once again white's king side attack
is sort of just leaving me unimpressed
with so many pieces
kind of committed to the queen side
uh yeah as far as queen takes b2 uh
especially in this position
we are much more interested in
developing these pieces rapidly
than sort of snagging this pawn
immediately knight d5
is actually going to be a bit of an
issue for us we can't really take this
guy uh
just because our pieces are a little bit
too awkward here
a little bit too awkward falling over
themselves
so to speak so yeah queen b2 i wouldn't
really recommend even if it is playable
uh in this case it's not playable i like
just going for rapid development and
creating threats on the queen side
and in the center as we see here
um okay and so this was all stemming
once again
from the move 10 a3 we castle king's
side
and when white continues to attack we
continue
to expand on the queen side bringing
this knight to c5
bringing this pawn to b4 and then going
for rapid development
before white's attack ever really gets
off the ground
and that is basically
white's second option here of queen e2
once again
bishop bishop d2 runs into queen b4
with attacks to the center and queen e2
we go back to these lines of b5 and
b4 to follow as we were just examining
white's third option and i think best
option is to play this move
f3 shoring up these
weak pawns in the center eliminating the
threat
in this manner and from here i
do think it is black's best option to
simply castle
uh castling king's side sort of castling
into the attack
but in this case i do think it is going
to be okay
for black if white continues uh
sort of according to plan with something
like g5
well now knight fd7 and we have once
again
sorry not g6
we have another bonus of the queen on a5
uh pressuring this pawn on g5
so for example f4 knight c5
pressuring the center once again queen
f3
bishop d7 bishop e3 and something like
knight c6
and i didn't go too deep in this
particular variation
but once again it's going to be a
classic case of black just has all of
his pieces in the game
and white's breakthrough is is not so
clear
we're getting rid of some very important
attackers if i can draw my arrows
and i don't see how white's attack is
gonna break through
another case of f5 being not such a good
move
uh simply because it doesn't achieve
anything
and there are hanging pawns and hanging
rooks in the position
um okay so rather than
g5 i do think bishop e3 is a little bit
of a better try
not creating so so many weaknesses in
the center just yet
now for example knight fd7 h4
is preparing to launch the attack
further knight c6
getting developed i kind of
glossed over knight fd7 of course the
point being remove the knight from the
threat of g5 beforehand
and are controlling this square more
directly
knight c6 also just normal development
and
now it's probably in white's best
interest to take this knight off the
board
if you sort of callously ignore it i
will
likely be taking on d4 here
and bringing this queen out to e5 and
once again with good centralization
uh black should be doing uh okay and so
knight takes c6 uh b takes c6
h5 and then i do think d5 is is the way
to go here
uh and after d5 black is sort of playing
in the center
to counter this attack on the king's
side
and it once again i i just don't see how
white is breaking through
in these lines black is ready to meet
the move h6 with the move g6
and we're going to reroute this bishop
out to f6 to help guard some of these
dark squares
and with a nice little central advantage
i do think
that uh black is doing quite all right
in in this case for example another move
queen e2 we are just ready to play
bishop f6
and get ready for these types of ideas
okay and so those are pretty much those
three
main variations after the move a g4
bishop d2 queen e2 and
f3
okay so any questions on the hg4 line
sorry pause to to read the chat again
any questions on these eight g4 lines
all right well then let's move on so
briefly i do want to talk about other
eighth moves
uh of course in week one i will say once
again we covered f4
and i do think g4 is the other you know
more critical try but i
i think this queen a5 move is affording
black some really good options
uh as far as other moves bishop e3 is
perhaps a good waiting move
but we can just continue now with b5 in
normal play
going after this guy if f4 we're
transposing i think directly
to some lines from the first lecture
just to move like bishop e7
and coming after this guy is going to be
plenty for black
if f3 uh black can simply castle here
something like queen d2 bishop b7 and
after
g4 knight fd7 we get sort of a slower
version
of some of the lines we were looking at
earlier where black hasn't played the
move queen a5
but the ideas here for black are are
going to be the same and they're going
to be a little bit less threatening
because black has taken or white has
taken the time to play these two moves
first
you don't get sort of the the rapid g5s
that you see
in some of the other main variations uh
just for example
if queen side castles knight c6 h4
knight c5 g5 even the move 95 here
and black is doing uh doing fine
ideas of controlling the c4 square ideas
of
a5 a4 ideas of knight takes b3
rook c8 even queen b6 or a5
are all in the air for black of course
b4
as well another critical idea here
uh other than that i did see someone in
the chat
last week mentioned the move bishop g5
so i just briefly wanted to
mention this move it isn't really the
most common move and i don't think it's
very critical
uh the reason i think bishop g5 is a
mistake is this is a move you'll see
white play
after black has committed to this move
e5 in many cases
but with this pawn back on e6 this
bishop on g5
isn't really doing too much it doesn't
really actually want to trade itself
off for this knight on f6 so i do think
bishop g5
is sort of just a mistake this bishop of
course would want to trade itself off
for this knight to gain control of the
d5 square
but in this case pawn's still on e6 this
just doesn't make
that much sense well i can continue
naturally with something like b5 or
knight c6
and just normal natural development in
this case
so g4 queen a5 someone in the chat is
saying castles
is best here for uh white i didn't
actually analyze this one
too much in depth i suppose this does
solve the threat
of knight takes e4 this has actually
never
been played so maybe this is one you'll
have to do your
your own homework on uh just briefly
looking with the computer here it does
look as though h6
is going to be perfectly fine here for
black
here white got a lot well i'm not so
sure what you're referencing
because this has never been played in
the history of chess
never been played i imagine play is
going to be
uh similar to what we've just looked at
uh play with knight c6
going for b5 and etc etc
uh play on the queen side and in the
center
it has an amateur games i'm sure in
amateur games but
at high levels this is apparently not in
my database
at the very least um okay maybe i'll
post an addendum
next week going over this line but i
don't
unfortunately have the prep for that
with me here castles just didn't really
occur to me
it's not the most natural move to play
g4 and then castle the king
just doesn't make a lot of sense to my
brain off the bat
but stay tuned next week i will have a
short
brief addendum to this lecture if you
are so concerned about this move
kingside castles um other than that
that's all of these
move eights uh option uh move eight
options you know we went over g4
went over bishop e3 went over the
slightly awkward bishop g5
of course castles is an option here but
we are sort of bundling that in with the
second half of this lecture
where i'm going over uh all of the lines
where white kind of just
castles king's side without further ado
let's
jump into those lines
all right zayat sharing his own personal
secret prep with me
i appreciate that but yeah i
unfortunately just don't have the prep
for kingside castles there in front of
me
what about uh queen f3 after bishop b3
okay let's
look at that briefly i think i did touch
on that
not in the lecture but in my notes here
if you play queen f3
so this idea is sort of
um to play against this move b5
and the reason i didn't touch on this
and i guess i should have
is that you just end up with a slightly
slower version of a line that you'll see
after kingside castles
and the truth of the matter is
um so sorry i'm actually recommending b5
after queen g3
the truth of the matter is that once you
get to this position
white's best move here is honestly just
to castle king side if you castle
queenside
you run into a huge problem with bishop
h4 and bishop takes f2
when this pawn is actually sort of
rather important
and this bishop is going to uh trade
itself off for this knight on d4
with some really uh unfortunate tactics
to follow as well
so white's best move here is to castle
king side and then we're gonna jump into
this position
uh really really shortly here
uh so let's go over the castle's king
side variations
so seven castles king side the move
i'm going to recommend rather than
bishop e7
this should be seven is sort of what i
was recommending uh against bishop e3
i do like just playing b5 directly here
and then following that up with bishop
e7 so
uh we still get this bishop on e7 but i
like playing b5 directly
just to challenge this guy and the
reason for that is if you played bishop
b7 here
then there is this move queen f3
uh amongst some other options i think a4
was
in particular the reason i didn't like
bishop b7 first a4 stopping b5
was just a little bit too awkward for my
taste
so b5 first bishop back to b3 and now
bishop out to e7
and so let's start with this move queen
f3 that we were
talking about moments ago
and here you can simply just play
the main move which is queen c7 this is
the move that i like
and the point now is that you're ready
to meet any threats to this rook with
the move bishop b7 you're just guarding
this square
directly the idea now of queen f3
is to follow through with queen g3
coming after this pawn
and rather than any crazy sacrifices i
do like just castling king's side
bishop h6 and now knight eight
uh and this position looks familiar
probably because
we just found it with the king still in
e1 and i was saying that kingside
castles is the best move
so this is uh the idea behind all that
uh now there are a few different moves
here for white that have been played
rook a to d1 is by far the most common
uh and here i do think bishop d7 the
main move
is quite simply the best
uh the idea is you are just developing
this bishop supporting your b5 pawn
and not losing track of the very
important e6 pawn
which white is always sort of
threatening in the back of his mind to
capture uh and now
amongst the various moves knight f3 has
arisen as
the most popular i think it's also the
least
challenging it's the more positional
approach but we'll look at it
uh briefly here knight f3 you can simply
develop
with knight c6 and after bishop f4 the
point of white's play now has sort of
changed from checkmate
to playing against this d6 pawn but
queen b7
is sort of very very adequate here for
black stepping out of the pin
and now rookie one for example to defend
is going to be met with b4
knight e2 and this move e5
uh after bishop g5 bishop e6 we have
arrived at a game
between gary kasparov and boris gelfand
with the black pieces all the way back
from the 1990s
but this is a case of that's
that game actually holding up here black
was doing just fine
uh in the game knight h4 was played
and now in the game that i just
referenced
knight a5 was actually played and this
gives white a little bit of an advantage
but the move bishop g5 is just fine
for black queen g5 and now knight a5
with this inserted is a bit better
what's the difference let me actually
check
so if knight a5 immediately bishop d5
here here
i guess we arrived at the same position
didn't we ah the difference is
white could have inserted this move
bishop takes c7 and this actually would
have been
really useful here for white although he
didn't so you take first
and then play knight a5 bishop d5 takes
takes now this knight comes in to c4
and after knight g3 you have a little
bit
of some scary business on the king's
side but
black can actually go ahead and just
take a free pawn
after knight f5 the one key defensive
move is
f6 and now quite simply there's there's
no way to
continue this attack on the king's side
black's pieces
are placed too well defensively there's
really no way
to break through this sort of lateral
defense with the queen and the knight on
e8 and the rook on f8
these knights are just not going to be
well enough placed to
continue this attack so after the
moverix c8 the move queen
b3 was played in the game sort of giving
up on this king-side attack and going
after some play on the queen side
and it was enough for a draw in this
game
g6 drove this knight away rick f7
and we found equal play now on the
queen's side with white regaining his
pawn
but not much more and they agreed to a
draw
here and this game was all actually also
gary kasparov
and boris gelfand but they arrived at
this position
through some slightly different uh move
orders
uh so once again what we have here
is uh queen g3 tax g7 so castles
threatens mates so knight eights rick
ad1
bishop d7 and knight f3 was the more
positional approach where black
can just develop the pieces and e5 is a
nice idea
to alleviate some of this pressure
other options here for white include
this move f4
and i do think this is the more
aggressive approach
for white it's a legit idea uh yeah f6
is a really nice defensive move there uh
a lot of times when you have a major
piece sort of on the seventh rank or
second rank
playing f6 or f3 is a good defensive
idea because then that piece can
sort of uh participate in the defense
along
that seventh rank defending the g7 pawn
um so f4 is another idea
that white can employ here going for
more direct
attacking ideas but once again it's not
going to be enough here to
sort of rattle black's cage we can just
develop with knight c6
and now it really is in white's best
interest to capture this guy
if you don't capture this guy and just
continue with f5
we get an improved version where we get
to bring this bishop out to f6 with
tempo
and then out to e5 with tempo on the
queen and
white is doing well uh in this position
once again uh f6 g6 and we are actually
quite happy
to sacrifice this exchange in in most
cases
uh this is from a game of mirozovich
against gary kasparov
uh and that one continued 92. a5
and this exchange was sacrificed queen
h4
a4 queen takes h7 and then kasparov
actually unfortunately went a little bit
astray
with queen a7 check the best move here
is the simple
bishop takes f6 sort of consolidating on
the the king of sight here and of course
there there are some moves left to be
played but i think black is simply
winning in this position
so you know hopefully you would be able
to figure out
over the board what gary kasparov
couldn't um
i say that as a joke but in all reality
after bishop takes f6 it's
sort of difficult to continue the attack
if something like rook
uh rook over to e3 there are a variety
of moves that win but the simplest
is probably just taking here giving some
material back
and playing bishop e8 and while black is
not up any pieces anymore
the entire queen sight is sort of
falling apart and
this knight is not playing and this king
is actually going to end up a little bit
weak
once these major pieces sort of invade
uh other options if
white does capture this knight and then
of course we don't get this bishop f6 to
e5 maneuver but we can take on c6
play king h8 uh king itch of course
making a threat and this leads to more
forcing variations if white wants to
continue the attack he has to play this
move f6
and now g takes h6 f takes e7 queen
takes c7
this is a rather scary extra pawn
for black with some issues on the king
side structure
but after a move like knight g7
uh black ends up doing okay in in most
cases
uh this one for example was rustam
khasam
janav against boris gelfand uh back in
2014
and it was eventually drawn here i
skipped over those last moves rather
quickly black actually has various
options that are all fine
so it's not like this is stuff you have
to memorize g takes h6
sorry um g takes h6 and queen e7 are
rather important but from here black
does have a lot of options
uh knight g7 was just sort of a nice
defensive idea
you know giving this pawn some mobility
in some cases defending
some important squares here and just
blocking off this diagonal
then this queen sort of came in and
black just played naturally
with play on the queen side
uh okay other 13th moves here other than
knight f3
white can try this move a3 going to
stop b4 once again though you just
develop naturally with knight c6
we have knight takes c6 bishop takes c6
rook fe1
and you just develop on the queen side
and this bishop once again
it was sort of a one-trick pony and is
running out of things to do on the h6
square
uh in a game between judo polgar and
vichy and nant
bishop g5 was played we had takes takes
and just rick b8
and this game was also eventually drawn
with judith uh immediately playing e5
and
uh vichy just taking on e5 and playing
queen b6
and this is perfectly fine here for
black
zayat is hitting me with more of his
personal prep saying
rather than knight f3 or any of the
moves i'm suggesting
knight c to e2 is something you can face
and once again
it's going to be another case of just
developing naturally with a move like
knight c6
and king h8 and once again these pieces
are running out of things to do a very
similar idea to the move a3
with the uh slight change that the pawn
is on c3 instead to stop this b4 idea
and white has sort of gone back uh
voluntarily uh play might continue
bishop g5
bishop takes g5 queen takes g5 and
knight back out to f6
and this is also fine for black
okay zayad has more more personal prep
for me
king h8 he wants to play bishop c1
followed
by f4 unfortunately though it's not so
easy to do all this as this pawn is
sort of under direct threat i don't know
maybe queen e3 here
uh but i think this is just sort of fine
here
for uh for black i don't think these f4
threats
are coming with too much velocity
or ferocity just more play on the
queen's side
uh okay he wants bishop c2 we can play
b4
uh and we could go on like this this for
for a while here but i do think this is
sort of now
outside the scope of opening preparation
and this is just going to be
uh sort of a middle game here like
bishop c1 is is a fine move
but this is a okay
why not bishop takes g7 well we we do
have this guy defended right this was
the point of the knight on e8
uh okay
so i believe those are all really the
the 13th moves here for white that i
that i
kind of had to cover once again this
line was after king's side castles
and this idea of queen f3 we're meeting
with queen c7
queen g3 is sort of the point we have
king side castles bishop a
h6 knight eights now after rook at d1
i'm saying this move bishop d7 uh other
moves
you can play rook e1 here if you really
like but the play is going to be largely
the same with something like bishop d7
uh for example a3 knight c6
and something like this could ensue or
if zayd prefers can go knight ce2 and
knight c6
with something similar even queen takes
c6 here
uh and the like i said the play is going
to be very very similar to what we just
looked at
a lot of the time rick ad1 gets played
anyways
uh and the point once again is largely
that this bishop on h6 sort of runs out
of things to do
it stops having the ability to generate
so many nasty threats
okay so other than queen f3
uh does white have other options well
yes
of course he does
so queen f3 is a nice idea to play
against b5
but we've seen those lines do turn out
okay for black
after this idea of queen c7 white can
also try
this move f4 sort of reverting back to
these
attacking ideas and the idea here
is going to be the idea in most cases
when white plays f4
we are going to go after the weakness
that this creates on the e4 pawn
so i'm going to recommend the immediate
bishop b7
to just challenge this guy directly and
now here white does have a couple
options
the move f5 we'll talk about first and
foremost i think this is just a bit of a
mistake
it allows this good structure that we've
talked about previously
f5 e5 when this guy is just going to be
a bit too weak this knight has to
retreat
black brings this knight out to c5 and
white is definitely on the back foot
in these positions uh more reasonable
tries
are the move e5 to save this pawn
we would get d take c5 f takes e5 and
here the difference is we don't
necessarily have to play knight of d7
which would be rather disastrous after
some really cool sacrifices
but we do have some tactical means here
of saving the game
with the move bishop c5 and after bishop
e3
we pile on the pressure with knight c6
and black is sort of our white is sort
of obliged to take on f6 now
and we go ahead and take on d4
now once again there is some stuff
to know here white has tried this move f
takes g7 a few times
it turns out this is in fact just a
losing variation
for white if black plays a few accurate
moves
we go ahead and capture free bishop with
check why wouldn't we
king h1 rook g8 is very natural queen f3
and now we're actually happy to take on
g7
white's best move here is actually to
play queen takes e3
but this allows queen d4 and now it's
very very difficult to avoid the queens
coming off the board
black's gonna castle queenside if you
try to avoid it anyways
and it's going to be black with a better
attack
so a better try for white might be
bishop takes e6 which has been played a
few times
but after the move queen e7 defending f7
attacking a bishop
defending our bishop white is is simply
lost
bishop d5 knight d4 queen h3
and now any number of moves win here
king f8 knight c2 bishop d2 it's sort of
all winning
for black at this point uh maintaining
an extra piece
uh okay if white doesn't play f takes g7
well then it's a lit
a bit simpler the queens just come off
the board and we get very similar
positions
except for the fact that uh
queens are already off the board white
or black doesn't have quite as much
immediate pressure
but black definitely isn't doing badly
here either in fact i do think it is
black with a slight advantage
in this position what's the decision to
put the bishop
on d7 over b7
i've lost which line we're talking about
to be honest
um a lot of the time it's when
the sacrifice on e6 is sort of tempting
for uh four white that's that's when we
would put the bishop on d7 here
uh to make those ideas a little bit less
powerful
i i don't even remember which line of
recommended bishop d7 in
uh i think it's been a bit i think in
all these castles variations so we're
putting this bishop on
b7 in most cases
uh except here except here we're putting
the bishop on on d7
so here the idea yeah it's it's this
it's the sacrifice
i think i mentioned um
i mentioned when i recommended the move
this sacrifice is sort of just an
issue for black if he isn't careful here
uh that is an added benefit of this
bishop on h6
is it does kind of draw this bishop to
d7 instead
so definitely be on the lookout for that
one okay
back to what we were just talking about
though sorry to jump around e5
and these lines are good for black
or roughly roughly equal
maybe slightly better for black in in
many cases
here so
that's the move e5 alternatively white
can try and sacrifice this pawn
with the move bishop e3 and now it would
be a bit of a mistake to actually take
on e4
i've talked about a similar position in
last week's lecture
here if you take on e4 you run into this
move
f5 and the problem now is we've sort of
given up
on the d5 square by taking this e4 pawn
for example knight or e5 runs
into first of all some sacrifices second
of all knight takes c4
she picks e4 and actually yeah it is the
sacrifices that are the problem here
uh with knight e6 and queen h5
to follow so we are not so happy to take
this pawn immediately
but we are slightly happier to play this
move b4
when this guy has to move if he
does do so moving uh for example the
knight a4
now we are happy to take this guy with
the bishop and the difference here
is that we're guarding this square quite
thoroughly
so this sacrifice comes with a lot less
impact with knight h5
being guarded uh if knight d5 this is
sort of a funny sacrifice
but we can in fact just capture this guy
e5 isn't doing too much
uh in the only game i see in the
database d takes e5 was played
uh which is i think the best move
actually f takes e5
and we can simply give this piece back
with castles and
black is doing just fine here as well
you might claim that d5
is a little bit weak but i would argue
that b2
is just as weak and there's no
immediate threats on the king's side for
example knight f5
we can just develop our pieces
and things might begin to liquidate in
fact
with something like this and once again
black is going to be regaining
something over here on the queen side
uh other than that after b4 e5 can be
tried once again
but it's another case of we just return
this piece
and take on c3 and black is doing well
once again um okay
so that is castles followed by 9
queen f3 and 9 f4
there are some other moves to talk about
as well
for example if bishop e3 you can just
castle king's side
and now if f4 the immediate b4
is hitting a bit harder
and it turns out this bishop e3 move was
actually more useful for black than it
was
for white in delaying f4 because now
after we've castled
we uh are still quite firmly defending
the e6 square
and so these uh type of moves do become
a bit better
but i actually do still recommend here
at the move bishop d7
uh in this case it's partially due to
preventing the sacrifices
it's also in fact making this move even
stronger because once again
f5 e5 runs into bishop d5
so in this case with bishop d7 let's say
waiting move
takes f5 e5 now the point
is sort of this bishop d5 move is never
going to be good
because this guy is sort of important
uh not to hang for example bishop takes
here pawn takes here
queen takes here knight f6 and black has
already taken
two pieces for the rook and is just
winning
okay so the point here bishop
e3 is sort of a waiting developing move
black can just castle
and now if white goes back to the normal
with stuff like f4
we're happy to play b4
and bishop d7 going after this pawn
on e4 if something like queen f3
defending the pawn we can just develop
with knight c6
and go about our business as usual with
pressure on
the queen side
uh okay other than that after castles
white can go back to stuff like f3
rather than going for f4 but i think
honestly
uh have i already covered this i haven't
well we'll talk about it here then
with f3 we can just develop a little bit
more naturally
something like bishop b7 or bishop d7
uh let's say bishop d7 just to stop the
sacrifices
uh queen d2 ac6
and its normal development once again
with play
once again coming on the queen side for
black
these lines with f3 are always going to
be a little bit less challenging
just because f4 f5 is really the fast
way to play
if with f3 especially when white hasn't
played
8g4 it's just sort of a slower way
of finding play on the king side and so
black's play
is a lot easier to come by with stuff
like b4
and playing on the queen side as i keep
saying over and over and over again
uh okay so that's bishop e3
as far as other options if a4 sort of
provoking b4
on move 9 here we are still happy to
play it
knight a2 is sort of a now positional
option
uh the point of these this move order by
white
is to sort of preemptively deal with
this idea of b4
and get this knight back to the square
on c3 sort of as quickly
as possible before black is really uh
well equipped to take advantage of it
uh once again knight takes e4 is going
to be uh
not ideal here in this case white is
just going to take back on b4
but i do like this move queen b6 here
for black just maintaining this pawn c3
is the natural follow-up
to get this knight back in the game b
takes c3
knight takes c3 simple uh the simple
castles
and after bishop e3 queen b7 is actually
a useful maneuver to keep in mind in
many positions
and we we are pressuring now uh e4
with the queen rather than the bishop
uh for example f3 defends the pawn and
we can go back
to normal development now with black and
this is in fact going to just be a
pretty good version
with these open lines already on the
board for black
uh okay so rather than a4
what else do i got for you guys if a3
trying to stop this pawn from ever
reaching the b4 square
uh the simple castles once again by
black
so sort of the default if white plays a
slow move in this position
now if f4 this is sort of the attacking
try
white can also go for these positions
that we were just looking at
but f4 is the attacking try to look at
bishop b7
f5 e5 knight d e2
maybe d7 and once again it's
uh another case of these sort of
positionally difficult positions for
white that i do think are just going to
be better
for black in these cases and once again
we talked about these positions a little
bit more in depth in
in the week one lecture and i
think that is uh pretty much all there
is to say
on these variations in the fischer susan
attack
uh so i'd like to uh to take
any questions from the chat zayad
seems to be the resident so is an expert
if he's got anything
he thinks i missed once again expect a
brief addendum
for that castle's variation that he kind
of threw at me as a curveball
uh throwing in ideas that were not in my
database
does they follow another lesson so yeah
of course we are going to continue this
series on the night or
but uh next week definitely won't be on
the fischer susan because i i have sort
of covered
really all the main options here for
white
and some very much sidelines that are
not often seen uh hopefully you feel
equipped enough
with the ideas you don't necessarily
have to memorize
all of this theory uh but
there are sort of uh four or
five i would say main really ideas that
you can play against the white setup
here
we added a few more today with these
ideas the early g4
there's those critical lines with e5 and
then from then you you just sort of uh
sort of play chess right that's that's
the whole shebang
uh okay well i think we are going to
call it there for tonight's episode of
chess openings explained
hopefully you do feel good about this
fisher-sozen variation uh wherein
i am recommending an early bishop e7
against all of white's main options in
fact
against just all of white's options i'm
recommending an early bishop e7
uh hopefully you feel well enough
prepared on that stay tuned for a
mystery lecture
next week on some other line of the
night or i think i might
step away from these super theory heavy
lines
next week so i'm not jumping right into
bishop g5
i know everybody wants to see what i'm
going to say about bishop g5
but i need i need a week of something a
little bit easier
than these these sews in and bishop g5
lines where
black is just always getting attack
detect attacked
uh so we'll talk about something new
next week
uh until then thank you so much for
joining me on this week of chess
openings explained
my name